i was talking to peter schweitzer
yesterday
and if you guys don't know who peter
schweitzer's kai you want to pull up on
google who peter schweitzer is
uh peter schweitzer is uh uh
there you go peter schweitzer he is the
former uh william j casey research a
fellow
at stanford university hoover
institution okay peter schweitz he's
written a lot of books go to amazon so
we can show the books
he's written a lot of they're just
typing right there amazon the bottom
right their third one is him
there you go you can do that as well so
he's written a lot of books now
obviously it's one-sided he wrote
clinton cash
which affected the last election okay
and that book got i don't know how many
thousands of views
reviews that affected clinton because
everybody talked about
clinton cash profiles and corruption he
breaks down
everybody left right middle everybody
mcconnell family everybody
uh and the recent one is secret empire i
asked him a question yesterday i think
we were having this conversation i said
i want to bring it up today
the question was who are the most
powerful
organizations or individual in america
today and before you guys answer
i actually want to hear from you as well
that you're watching this and i want you
to rank this so hear me out when i'm
saying this
because i want to hear you rank these in
the comments section okay so
adam if you're ready hi i want to hear
from you as well
uh uh uh you were in it so you can't
play along luis i want you to think
about the answers here as well eric
youtube i've forgotten if that matters
yeah
i'll tell you right now you told me i
asked them a question i said who are the
most powerful people in america today
i said number one the president of the
united states
okay i just said not in a list i'm just
saying yeah this is one
is president united states second one is
billionaires
third is universities fourth is
social media companies fifth is
mainstream media
who's the most powerful let me read it
again presidents
billionaires universities social media
companies
or mainstream media once again
presidents
billionaires social media companies
universities
or mainstream media from first
to last who do you say is the most
powerful to the least powerful his
answer was shocking and i agree with him
first or last who would you say i'm
going to step out because i know the
answer because
i'll have some comments later okay you
go ahead who's from the most powerful to
the least powerful
most i have just
off the top of my head here most
powerful right now in america
are social media companies okay so
social media for you is the top
i would put number two media um
[Music]
for some reason i i feel like the
president according to this list would
be last
although i i would disagree with that um
i got billionaires and universities
coming in at three and four and
you got billionaires third you got
billionaires third university
university's third okay university third
fourth
and then president last yeah
okay president's last what do you say
luis who's the most powerful eric who's
the most powerful so i'm
i'm kind of going that way but i'm going
to flip the one and two let's do media
mainstream media first then social media
okay all right cool
i like that eric what do you say i think
it's social media then it's
uh media then it's universities then
it's billionaires and then there's the
president so you guys are identical
the two of you are identical kai who do
you have and he's a conservative
uh i say universities
or social media first then universities
then media then billionaires than the
president hang on so social media first
then universities mainstream media then
mainstream media
uh billionaires and then president okay
so here's what he said
okay here's what he said and we got a
lot of different people here you know
energized with andres royal family ryan
lin says msm social bureaus college
presidents that's it so msm's first then
social media companies then billionaires
then college universities and presidents
for ryan lynn
juan guzman put social media and
billionaires are the same thing to him
okay ron harris is illuminati great we
went to a completely different direction
there but okay i'm gonna give you a
shout out all right so here we go here's
what he said
number one at the top social media
companies okay most powerful
yeah most powerful zuck is the most
powerful non-elite in the
world the world not just not elected if
he's the most powerful in the world wow
zuck is the most powerful if he ran for
office
he dictates everything he is demo so he
said socialist first
he said universities are second
he said presidents congress third
is what he put fourth he put uh
mainstream media
fifth he put billionaires he says
billionaires are irrelevant today
he says no one cares if you're a
billionaire there's so many of them
billionaires don't matter
they used to 30 years ago but they don't
do today there's a lot of billionaires
if i read the forbes 2000 or fourth one
you wouldn't know
80 of the names if i read the names to
you okay
so social universities
president msm then billionaires thoughts
thoughts number one
what a scary list it's it's completely
horrifying and i'll tell you why
because you look at number one and
number two and you could put
media at number three mainstream if you
wanted to three of the five
60 percent don't entertain other
thoughts
than their own they they will shut you
down
if you have a conflicting opinion than
them on social media and don't think
they don't know their power
either they know exactly how powerful
they are they just showed it
um and the other thing universities as
number two if that's what he says that's
scary too because they're not allowing
any other thought
in liberal arts universities you are not
allowed
to have a conflicting opinion of him and
if you look at the numbers of people
that
um professors in college it's like 35 to
one
when it comes to a conservative versus a
liberal 13 to one 13 to one washington
time okay and not only that
but they're they're militant they they
won't just hey i disagree with you i
respect your thought or something like
that
they they will shut you down they they
will attack you
so to me this is a very very frightening
thing and they're only getting more
powerful yeah
adam yeah i think we all
agreed that social media was number one
especially these days i mean we're
seeing
you know in congress just last week who
got who had to show up
zuk jack dorsey looking like zz tops um
uh how do we say the ceo of google's
name how do we say his name anyone
anyone anyone
sundar pinchai thank you for that kai
our uh
our 22 year old who's able to vote these
days uh social media number one i think
you know that's a scary situation
university's number two why are
universities number two you think
because they're training the next crop
of people that are coming out to
what they believe what percentage of
americans go to university 25
the ones that are the cultural elites
that end up on the coast that dictate
everything that's going on in this
country we got a point it's the people
that end up
i mean think about it right now the
ticket to getting a nice job is through
what a degree
so if you get a nice that's what you're
getting it is changing but it's been
like this for a while
universities out as of right now has
extreme
influence are we saying that it's the
universities or the products of the
universities meaning like you go to
harvard you become a
you know no it's the universities what
they're training you the the culture
i'm sure that's what i mean it's a
cultural thing with professors what
they're doing you're saying
it's the teachers the professors
the professor like you know you are
going to be taught by a professor on
whatever he or she thinks
well these days so online it's hard to
get influence as much
and then what president was number three
president was number one where was
number
three where was president you know 50
years ago now for probably first place
number one
right and he lumped congress into that
number yeah he did he said congress he
specifically said congress on president
well thank god that you know the
president doesn't have
ultimate say you know congress but the
point is the point is the president is
no longer the most powerful man on the
planet it's no longer that's no longer
the case
guys twitter is censoring the president
think about what i just said right there
twitter censors the president twitter
dictates what the president can say
and not say who has the power president
president can't tell twitter hey
show what i have to say that that is uh
you right there you realize who really
has the power
it ain't no president and to even
document that more when the president
can actually showcase the power he has
it's through social media i mean that's
where trump has his most power
when he's communicating to his base
through social media which even
further illustrates how powerful it is
[Music]
you